وشهد تونس خلال الاسابيع الاخيره حمله
ايقافات شملت عددا من الوجوه السياسيه
والاعلاميه والنقابيه ففي الحادي عشر من
الشهر الحالي اعتقلت قوه الامن رجل
الاعمال كمال لطيف ووزير الماليه الاسبق
والقيادي السابق في حزب التكتل من اجل
العمل والحريات خيام التركي الى جانب
القياديه السابق في حركه النهضه عبد
الحميد الجلاصي وبعد يوم تم اعتقال رئيس
محكمه التعقيب السابق الطيب راشد وقاضي
التحقيق السابق البشير العكرمي الذي كان
مكلفا بملف اغتيال السياسيين المعارضين
شكري بالعيد ومحمد السياسيين المعارضين
شكري بلعيد ومحمد الابراهمي وفي اليوم
التالي اعتقلت اجهزه الامن القيادي في
حركه النهضه نور الدين البحيري كما اوقفت
مديره محطه موزاييك اف ام الايداعيه نور
الدين بوطار والمحامي والناشطه السياسي
الازهر العكرمي وفي السبت الماضي اعلن
رئيس التونسي الامينه العامه للاتحاد
النقابات الاوروبيه
غير مرغوب فيها وامر بمغادرتها البلاد في
غضون 24 ساعه مضيفا ان مشاركتها في احتجاج
اتحاد الشغل التونسي وتصريحاتها كانت
تداخلا سافرا في الشؤون التونسيه